Choose a random street, in a random neighborhood,
on a random day in Toronto, and odds are
the first person you see – not including
tourists! – won’t have been born in Canada.
51% – or 1.4 of its 2.7 million residents – are
immigrants – significantly more than Los
Angeles, San Francisco, or even New York.
Last year, Canada welcomed 437,000 new permanent
residents – 1% of its entire national population.
When you count all new residents – permanent
and not – the nation grew by 2.7% – making
it the 16th fastest-growing country in the world
and the only one of these not in Africa or Asia.
And yet, Canada is just getting started.
13 years from now, immigrants are expected to make
up 30% of the population, compared to 23% today.
Now compare that to the “melting pot”
known as the United States of America.
When you ask Americans how many immigrants they
think are in the country,
the average answer is 40%.
In fact, every demographic group – White,
Black, Latino, Asian, Liberal, Conservative,
even immigrants themselves – vastly
overestimates the true number… just 14%.
Here’s a list of the 34 countries and
territories with a larger share of
immigrants per capita than the U.S.
After removing small countries –
those with a population under 10
million – you can see what actually
sets America apart: its size.
The United States is the largest country that
accepts a significant share of immigrants.
But, as a share of the population,
Canada, far more than America,
is truly a nation of immigrants.
Even more striking is the large
number of young engineers,
doctors, and scientists settling
in Canada over the United States.
Nearly the same number of documented
employment-based immigrants entered
Canada as the U.S. in 2022, despite
being only one-tenth as large.
No offense to our exceptionally
friendly Northern neighbors, but… why?
The simple answer is that immigrating to
the United States is an insanely difficult,
stressful, costly, lengthy, and arbitrary
process, while immigrating to Canada… isn’t.
To see how, let’s compare the journeys
of two hypothetical immigrants.
“Sanjay” and “Rohan” were both born in India.
They both scored in the 95th-percentile on
their college entrance exams, and both
received scholarships to study abroad.
Sanjay, to Columbia in New York;
and Rohan to McGill in Montreal.
After graduating, Rohan is allowed to work
in Canada for three additional years. Sanjay,
one year, or three with a STEM major.
So far, so good. But then the paths of our
two immigrants rapidly begin to diverge.
Assuming Sanjay doesn’t have a million dollars
to invest or a close U.S. Citizen relative,
he’ll be thrown into the grueling H-1B gauntlet.
The H-1B is a high-skill visa for in-demand
“specialty” occupations like
programmers and accountants.
To try for one, Sanjay will need to find
an employer who agrees to pay him no less
than the “prevailing wage” for that
job and to sponsor his application.
But that alone is no guarantee – far from it.
For the last twenty years, Congress
has limited the number of H-1Bs to
65,000 per year, with an additional
20,000 for those with advanced degrees.
And in every one of those years – typically
in less than 5 days – more than the maximum
85,000 people have applied.
Sanjay, therefore, will have to play the lottery.
Despite attending one of America’s
best schools, receiving a perfect GPA,
mastering English, and acclimating
well, his name will be thrown,
along with thousands of others,
into a random number generator.
At this point, he’ll likely lose
and be kicked back to square one.
In a good year, 43% of applicants are
selected. In a bad one, like last year,
just 14.6% – though the Department of Homeland
Security attributes this to a rise in fraud.
After educating Sanjay for years,
America will unintentionally gift
his valuable knowledge and
labor to another country.
At the exact moment he’s ready to
contribute to the U.S. economy,
he’ll be forced to either leave or go
back to school and delay his employment.
But let’s assume he’s one of the lucky few.
Having been selected, U.S. Citizenship and
Immigration Services will look – for
the first time – at his application.
If he’s then approved, Sanjay will join the tiny,
elite circle of America’s
most fortunate immigrants.
In 2021, the median wage for all U.S. workers
was $45,000. For H-1B holders, it was $108,000.
Even many of the lowest-paid H-1B holders
make more than 75% of all Americans.
If he chooses to, Sanjay will
live a life of abundance.
He’ll drive a nice car, live in a big
house, and eat at nice restaurants.
But although he’ll likely be
financially comfortable, legally,
he’ll exist in a perpetual
state of anxious precarity.
That’s because the H-1B is not a green
card. It’s a temporary work visa.
For one, this means travel is
more complex. Leaving the country,
even for a few days, requires permission.
And, though unlikely, Sanjay will only be
one irritable border guard away from being
locked out of the place he’s spent
most of a decade building a life in.
Secondly, Sanjay doesn’t have permission to work.
He has permission to work for a specific employer.
If he’s fired or laid off, he’ll have
60 harrowing days to find a new company
willing to sponsor his visa, or else pack up
and, along with his family, leave the country.
Now, to escape this absurdity,
Sanjay needs a green card.
And, in theory, he’s already eligible to apply.
But only his employer can apply on his behalf.
In other words, the freedom
to leave one’s employer must,
in most cases, be approved… by that very employer.
This process is not cheap. And
only his company is allowed to pay.
So, unless Sanjay’s skills are
truly irreplaceable or his employer,
unusually generous, he may have to wait.
After 3 more years, he’ll need to renew his H-1B,
which can only be done once and
since 2004, requires – for no
clear reason – traveling back to your home
country’s U.S. consulate and re-entering.
If Sanjay hasn’t found an employer
willing to sponsor his green card
after another 3 years, he’ll be forced to leave.
But, again, let’s assume he’s lucky.
After finding a sponsor, proving he won’t
negatively impact the wages of U.S. workers,
and that there are no other qualified
candidates, Sanjay will finally… start waiting.
Because, not only does Congress
limit the number of green cards,
it also sets a limit per country. And that
number is the same regardless of its population.
1.4 billion people live in India. Five million in
Norway. But the two countries
have the same annual limit.
Naturally, more Indians and Chinese apply than
Norwegians, which creates a backlog of the former.
As of July 2023, these are the “priority dates”
for this type of green card. What this means is
that Indians who applied on the 1st of January,
2009 are just now receiving their green cards.
Across all nationalities and all categories,
these are the average wait
times to receive one as of 2018.
22% waited between 10 and 19
years. 5% waited 20 years or more!
In the meantime, Sanjay will be
stuck in limbo – a temporary worker,
tied to a single employer,
potentially for decades.
During this time, he may watch as someone
from a smaller country enters the U.S. for
the first time, receives a green
card, and then even citizenship.
Now, back to Rohan.
Because he’s worked in Canada, Rohan is
eligible to apply for “Express Entry”.
It – unlike the H-1B lottery –
is transparent and predictable.
It’s based on a point system.
Anyone can go online right now, enter
things like your English proficiency,
work experience, and age, and immediately
see your score. It takes about two minutes.
Every few weeks, the government invites
everyone with a certain score to apply.
Previous cut-offs are listed
clearly on the website.
If Rohan has a job offer in Canada,
he’ll very likely be approved.
After that, not only will he not
be tied to a specific employer,
but he won’t receive a work visa at
all. He’ll receive permanent residency.
And because Canada has no discriminatory
per-country limit, he’ll receive it
immediately and be treated the same as
anyone from Norway, Nigeria, or Nepal.
In other words, Rohan and his family
will live with a degree of security
and stability that Sanjay may not achieve for
another decade or longer. And that’s assuming
Sanjay won the lottery and only has to wait
a very optimistic 4 years for a green card.
When viewed this way, it’s really not surprising
that so many high-skill workers immigrate to
Canada. What’s surprising is that, despite this
Kafkaesque bureaucracy, many still prefer America.
On this, the data is pretty unambiguous.
In a 2021 Gallup survey, of the 900 million
people worldwide who wish to immigrate, nearly
20% said the United States was their first choice
destination – far more than any other country.
And among high-skill immigrants,
that number is likely much higher.
The number one reason is money.
Most H-1B jobs are business, science,
engineering, or computer-related.
And, to be frank, Canadian tech salaries are
laughable by comparison. We’re talking less
than half the money for the same experience,
with the same responsibilities, and title.
An L5 Software Developer at Canada’s
Shopify makes something in the area of
$121,000 US Dollars. An L4 at Google
makes $264,000 and an L5 $367,000.
The higher you go on the org chart, the larger
the gap between U.S. and Canadian wages.
The most well-compensated software
engineers at Facebook, Google,
and Apple make $1-2 million a year. Those at
Shopify make something like 15-30% as much.
For this reason alone, a shocking
number of graduates from Canada’s
top universities pack up and move
South at the first opportunity.
Then you have Canadian housing.
An entire video should be devoted to this topic,
but for now, this graph should do the trick.
This is the growth in U.S. incomes since 2005
and this is the growth in U.S. housing prices.
Alright now here are Canadian
incomes, and Canadian housing.
No one has ever called San Francisco an
affordable place to live. But Toronto
and Vancouver aren’t much better, yet
their salaries are dramatically lower.
In 2021, nearly half of new immigrants to
Canada settled in Ontario. And of them,
the vast majority, in one city: Toronto.
That’s a problem because the average
selling price of a home across the
whole province of Ontario is $928,000.
In British Columbia, over a million.
In other words, housing prices provide
immigrants with plenty of reasons not to
settle in Canada and high salaries, plenty
of reasons to settle in the United States.
…They just can’t.
America’s current immigration policies were mostly
set in 1990 – when just 15% of households had a
personal computer. This was a time when virtually
none of the current H-1B jobs even existed.
Whatever flavor of reform you prefer,
we’re clearly past due for an update.
And until that day comes, Canada is very
happily filling this gap in the market.
Just this year, for instance, it announced a
plan to allow H-1B workers to move to Canada,
where they’d be immediately
unshackled from their employer.
This strategy of leveraging its proximity to
and similarities with the United States only
works because the American immigration
system is so unbelievably broken.
Canada need not address its severe
housing crisis or do the difficult
work of nurturing a Silicon Valley of the North.
Whenever a Harvard graduate loses the H-1B
lottery or an Indian national is stuck waiting
a decade or longer for a green card, Canada
need only do what America won’t: let them in.
Now, some may argue that American immigration
isn’t broken so much as it has
chosen different priorities.
In 2021, 60% of new permanent residents in America
were sponsored by family
and 26% by their employer.
In Canada, the two categories
are almost perfectly reversed.
There, 20% were family-based
and 62% for employment.
It may appear that America’s
goal is to unite families,
while Canada aims – first and
foremost – to strengthen its economy.
But what these numbers hide is the scale
of each country’s immigrant population.
True, a smaller share of new Canadian
immigrants are joining their families,
but only because Canada welcomes
so many immigrants in total.
In fact, per capita, it has more family-sponsored
permanent residents than the U.S.
The same is true of humanitarian immigrants.
Canada admits nearly twice
as many refugees per capita.
It isn’t pro-wealthy immigrants to the
exclusion of others. By most measures,
it’s pro-immigrant, full-stop.
Today, for example, nearly 70% ‘disagree’
that “Immigration levels are too high”.
Perhaps even more surprisingly,
a majority in all three of its largest
political parties support immigration.
These surveys suggest the country has
cultivated support for a multicultural
society as much as a mere willingness to
tolerate newcomers when economically convenient.
…Speaking of convenience,
today’s sponsor, Trade Coffee,
delivers you a fast, fresh, and diverse
palette of coffee right to your doorstep.
After joining its over 100,000 monthly
subscribers, you’ll answer a few quick
questions about your preferences. Whether
you’re a coffee expert or beginner,
Trade will find the perfect fit for
you from over 450 selections across
the country — from dark roasts,
to espresso, blends, and more.
Next, within 48 hours of roasting,
your personalized coffee will be shipped
to your home for maximum freshness.
I just received this Seattle french roast, and
before that, a Huckleberry dark-roast from Denver.
Right now, you can get a free bag
of coffee with any subscription
by clicking the link on screen or
in the description below. That’s
drinktrade.com/polymatter . Thanks
to Trade for sponsoring this video.